don't really think about it too much
i think um
the story would be told how it's
supposed to be told it'd be written how
it's supposed to be written but
i don't live my life thinking about
legacy
um
what i do off the floor is what means
more to me
than what i do on the floor
how i
you know
seeing my kids on the
back of a wheaties box
yesterday
was one of the best moments of my life
and
seeing my mom
unveil the box back in my hometown of
akron ohio yesterday
with some of the best
news videos and pictures that i've ever
seen
that i could ever get
the game of basketball will pass me by
and
you know there's a new group of you know
young kids and vets and rookies
throughout the course of this game
hey listen lebron james right there not
the uh
you're not the only kid from akron in
this conversation shout out
uh i love it i love when he mentions
that when he says hey i'm just a kid
from akron and i think
people i know he's written about this he
has a book uh mike i don't know if you
read it back in the day probably man
goodness like
15
14 years ago did a book with buzz
bissinger
you know talking about his friendship
with his high school teammates and
talking a lot about akron
if you go to akron
and then think that lebron james is
possibly the best player ever to play
the game then you'll understand what he
means when he talks about
how he overcame the odds and like how
significant this is so but i didn't want
to talk about that but i always think
about
the best player in basketball history
may be from akron ohio and not just from
akron ohio mike you know some of the
places that that he talks about where he
grew up
so one of his uh i think one of his
companies or uh
it's called spring hill right mm-hmm
yeah spring and entertainment
so that that's about five minutes from
five minutes from where i grew up
uh it is not
you know
people people in in spring hill spring
hill and and the street derick that i
grew up on molar avenue
there are a lot of people talking about
these big dreams and hey you can do
anything that you want and one day
you'll be on tv one day you'll be famous
one day you'll be uh
a school planter and you'll be over a
voting drive and you'll be one of the
most successful
businessmen in the world on top of
being a great basketball player it's
just
right that wasn't right what that vision
wasn't there so what he's doing right
now
is significant and i really appreciate
him for that alone even if he had turned
into a
let's say a seven-time all-star
and a one-time nba champion shouting out
akron ohio that would have been
that would have been pretty big but what
he has done
is
you just got to go to that area
to really put it in perspective
so i appreciate that part of lebron
no no i feel you i i feel like every day
lately i think a lot of it's got to do
with
our relationship
um how we see things at this point in
our lives i mean
you know we we talked a lot all right
tangent time
uh
there's a segment tangent time uh we
talked a lot um
when we were first starting this show
about this journey for the two of us
and
it's been 20 years in the making and we
wanted to do something together
uh
you know back when i was at the globe
and and you were at the globe and you
know when i was at espn and and and you
know you were still in boston and i had
opportunities to start to develop
programming and so
but but everything in in it's in its
time and god's time and and but not we
talked about how we are at a better
place now to do this
not just in society but me and you
we're at a better place now to do this
than we were and would have been back
then
um
and to not just do it but to do it our
way i say that to say
uh our conversations
are are often philosophical whether it's
about uh fatherhood faith
family
you know our journeys whatever it is and
so i'm i'm thinking to myself
here we go down another
path because lebron has been the
inspiration for a lot of those
conversations it feels like this is our
wrapping up today is our fourth week on
the show and every time lebron is on the
first 20 years number 12. yeah it leads
us
it leads us down a conversation you know
that's much bigger than basketball you
know appropriately enough because he's
much bigger than basketball you know
he's more than an athlete as he's fond
of saying
and so yeah i'm with you 100 percent i
mean whether you know take out akron and
and and insert new orleans you know um
or any city usa
um
for a kid to
have come from
uh
the struggle that he come that he came
from and to do what he's done
on the court and off the court i mean i
i appreciated isaiah thomas's tweet
you know isaiah thomas put out a tweet i
think it was yesterday we have it
santa we have the best and most
complete basketball player
that he has ever seen
on and off the floor there it is there
it is
on and off the floor best and most quote
unquote complete
now we can certainly debate that
but then he says on and off the floor
yeah now somebody like you know kareem
abdul-jabbar or even bill russell or
in his own way michael jordan might want
to debate that but that's not that's we
shouldn't
reduce that to a debate let's just talk
about the off the floor part because
on the floor can be
on the floor can be subjective
because even though lebron may have on
the floor is subjective it is it is it
is yeah it is it did it on the floor
yeah it is i mean you know because
people like you know it's my opinion but
and i say the reason i say can be is
because
your numbers and your accomplishments
there's no
arguing that there's no argument arguing
the number of championships there's no
argument the number of finals mvps
there's no argument the number of points
rebounds assists in blocks and and
steals that he ultimately finishes with
all nba but even some of those accolades
are inherently subjective
he might have he might have more mvps
but i guess what i'm saying is when you
start to get in a goat conversation
you know i can take his numbers
and i can manipulate them to fit my
narrative you can take jordan's numbers
and manipulate them to fit your
narrative and so on and so forth what i
am saying though
is that having kids from the i promise
school
on a wheaties box
you know
pouring into your community
uh
empowering and encouraging people to
vote
those things are ironclad
that's ironclad
like i know lebron is a big movie guy
uh i know uh he likes gladiator
you know and there's a scene in
gladiator
uh you know where maximus is leading um
you know his army against the uh the
forces of germania
you know and and russell crowe's maximus
says what we do in life echoes
throughout eternity i know lebron is
fond of that fond of that line
and what he's doing with his life and
with the lives of others will echo
throughout eternity that is that is a
legacy you know an on-the-floor legacy
is
again subjective it's a matter of
opinion people can write the story
however they want rank it however they
want
his legacy as a man as a father as a
husband as a citizen as a philanthropist
as an entrepreneur
that's his and his alone and you can't
touch it
yeah it's great mike
no i love what you uh some of those
points just made
about him and one of the things that
stands out
about
about lebron james smee is
part of his story growing up
so he has mentioned that
you know he grew up not only did he grow
up without his father
um he also grew up at a time
uh i know his mother was there raising
him but he lived with other people too
and by the time the stat is crazy i
think by the time
he was in the third or fourth grade
he had missed an incredible amount of
school
like school time it's just
i'll get the number before the show is
over or somebody can google it uh it's a
new york times uh article from a few
years ago it will blow your mind
but that's not the point the point is
there are so many kids like that
who are dismissed
they're they're they're giving up they
they're either given up on by the system
sometimes they're given up on by their
own family sometimes they give up on
themselves
so for that part of the story he was
he was a kid on the margins
so this kid on the margins and i know
it's easy for people to say well you
know hey if i'm lebron james
i would do this that's not necessarily
true there are a lot of pitfalls along
the way it didn't have to happen this
way just because he's 6-8 and talented
doesn't mean that he was destined to be
here especially if you see the street
talent yeah that's right especially if
you see the streets that he grew up part
of like so many challenges
along the way
that's one part of the story that i
really like and the other thing is
uh you know you talk about how
subjective
it is on the court
or or it can be subjective and at times
you know the numbers speak for
themselves
this is why your point last week about i
think it was last week as you said the
day's counting did you hear gary just
now or did he just sell it to me no i
didn't hear what what was it what was
this i didn't hate it
it was 83 days in the fourth grade was
the number you were looking for he
missed 80. okay now think about this
think about this
you're supposed to be in school for 180
days
roughly
180 days
and you miss 83 days in the fourth grade
so let me just okay before i get to my
basketball point let me just pile on
here a certain host we're not going to
say her name a certain host
not only told him to shut up in the
dribble
oh okay
but she made a point to say
that he's just a high school graduate
right now what's the the irony of that
was so funny
is that
most of the people
who share
her politics and the politics of others
most people in the country are high
school graduates
sure that's a fact so why are you
insulting why are you insulting the
people who are watching you that's one
two
lebron james i've said this about lebron
james and kevin garnett
both guys who went from high school
straight to the pros
they are some uh they are two of the
most intelligent
worldly
observant people that i've ever
interviewed
so it's not like don't get caught up in
where did you go to school i i can't
stand that question when i meet educated
and intelligent don't always mean the
same thing if i ever meet you if i ever
meet you okay we
gotta end the conversation real fast
well okay so
where'd you go to school no you don't
care about that what you're trying to do
is get a sense of where should i slot
you
should i pitch should i pay attention to
you or not okay are you are you worthy
of this conversation i think that is
meaningless he's a very intelligent
person but the basketball part i was
going to say my
the reason i think is subjective
in some ways and the reason your your
analogy of stevie wonder prince
with michael jordan and lebron
is that it depends on what your focus is
like what's important to you
like one of the things that stands out
about michael jordan's
stats
is ten times scoring chip
and ten times scoring champ
that was important to him
to be a ten time scoring champ i'm not
dismissing it but that is part of that
tells you okay if you start with michael
jordan start with the score he was a
scorer he wanted to be a scorer i mean
that that was
that was his thing
whereas
and and and if you look at it and and if
you're a little skeptical
i'm listening
good good all right go back to work no i
just can't say you can go back to the
jordan rules where he says to uh
he says to a teammate man phil jackson's
not gonna let me be the scoring champ
he's really trying to switch up this
offense he's not gonna let me score
it doesn't diminish michael jordan but
he's a scorer
lebron james is not a 10-time scoring
champ could he have been
absolutely
he could get his whatever he wants
that's not that's not how he plays
that's not right really that's not
really the focus of his game now he'll
wind up with a ton of points
uh he may be the all-time leading scorer
before it's all been done
but it's like it so when we start
judging well this guy well how many
scoring titles did lebron have or like
you know you go lebron versus jordan uh
you go lebron versus kareem
it's all different based on who that
person is lebron
is the guy who just wants to do a little
bit of everything on the court well yeah
he enjoys he enjoys seeing his friends
and teammates as the case may be be as
as if not more successful in him he's
wired to make the right play